next question
trump's move to halt critical race
theory training is both bold
and the timing seems almost enlightened
have we been underestimating his
intelligence or does he have an
intuition that helped him make a smart
move in an opportune moment in history
yeah i mean we've in fact i think you
mentioned last time at the time before
that we've
i've called him a political savant and
and was calling him that not at the
point of the last election
but fairly shortly after that
um at which point i could you know at
that point
i hadn't seen anything to recommend him
at all you know this move
um this move and others since i do see i
do see that he has made some
some moves that are not just politically
savvy but also
what i would say are the right moves um
so this this strikes me as perfectly in
keeping with that
and you know is he more than that is he
more than a savant uh this is this is
something that you addressed i think
last time
well so i've been calling him a
political genius
and i've been telling the left that they
need to wise up because to the extent
that they treat him as a fool they keep
underestimating him
and handing him lots of tools
and also in this case as in some others
handing him the moral high ground which
is not something that the democrats
should want to do and yet they do it
again and again so in this case
we have the right move we have
the politically savvy move being the
same move
so we don't know what motivated this and
the question that i have
is what happens when a guy like
trump makes the right move and gets
lauded
for it will he develop a taste
you know and so can we train him our
trump supporting
viewers will bristle at this discussion
because i think you and i both feel that
trump is
i would say an entirely cynical actor
which doesn't mean he's always wrong
that's right um but it means that the
motivation is
advancing the political ball this is
where his genius is
um but to the extent that the right
thing to do
is to i mean the only thing to do
is to take the most essential
machinery of civilization and
immunize it from this insanity however
you do that so
this must be done the fact that lots of
us are looking
you know lots of us from across the
political spectrum who are paying
attention
know that the ship is being jeopardized
by
uh whether you see it as a psychotic
break a
emergent psychotic break on behalf of
the population an autoimmune
disorder um sabotage whatever you see it
as the answer is
you have to immunize the essential
features of
society from the you know from
gazing into their navel and wondering
what two plus two actually equals
right you have to stop that stuff and so
he's done it and it's a brilliant
political move
it's the right move will he get addicted
to doing the right thing and having
people
who are in other parts of the political
spectrum that don't usually recognize
him saying actually
pretty good stuff right let's hope
let's hope yeah right i i certainly
leave that possibility open and i
i hope for and to the extent that the
democrats are going to play their same
damn card and their point is going to be
if trump wants it then it's bad if
they're going to play
that which is what trump is counting on
in this case
then they are setting up a situation in
which lots of people who know how
dangerous this belief system is
and what it is threatening to do are now
in a pickle which is
you can't vote blue because blue is
inviting this stuff through the door
yeah so they're creating there there are
plenty of existential threats to go
around
how dare they create a new one because
it serves them politically
well said
[Music]
you